I started life as a fashion designer
working closely with textile designers
and fabric suppliers but today I can no
longer see or talk to my new
collaborators because they're in the
soil beneath our feet on the shelves of
our supermarkets and in the beer I'm
gonna drink when I finish this talk I'm
talking about microbes and designing
with life 15 years ago I completely
changed both what I worked with and how
I worked after a revelatory
collaboration with a biologist our
project gave me a different perspective
on life introducing a whole new world of
possibility around how we can design and
make things I discovered a radical
manufacturing proposition biofabrication
literally fabricating with biology what
does that mean well instead of
processing plants animals or oil to make
consumer materials we might grow
materials directly with living organisms
in what many are terming the fourth
Industrial Revolution we're thinking
about the new factories as being living
cells bacteria algae fungi yeast our
latest design tools include those of
biotechnology my own journey in
biofabrication started with a project
called bio catcher the provocation was
that instead of growing a plant like
cotton in a field over several months we
could use microbes to grow a similar
cellulose material in a lab in a few
days using a certain species of bacteria
in a nutrient-rich liquid we fermented
threads of cellulose that self organ
into a sheet of fabric I dried the
fabric I'd grown and cut and sewed it
into a range of garments shoes and bags
in other words in one lab we grew
materials and turned them into a range
of products in a matter of days and this
is in contrast to current methods of
fabric production where a plant is grown
just the cotton part is harvested
processed into a yarn woven into a
fabric and then potentially shipped
across oceans before being cut and sewn
into a garment all of that can take
months
so these prototypes indicated a field
offering significant resource
efficiencies from reducing the water
energy and chemistry needed in the
production of a material through to
generating zero waste
we grew fabrics to finished form if you
like biological additive manufacture
through biofabrication I had replaced
many intensive man-made steps with one
biological step and as I engage with
this living system it transformed my
design thinking here was biology with no
intervention from me other than
designing initial conditions for growth
efficiently producing a useful
sustainable material so now I can't help
but see all materials through the lens
of biofabrication in fact there's a
growing global community of innovators
rethinking materials with biology
multiple companies are now growing
mushroom materials but not literally
mushrooms using mycelium which is the
root system of fungi to bind together
agricultural byproducts and it's a
process that's being described as
nature's
blew a common way to do this is to take
a 3d mold fill it with a waste crop like
corn stalks or hemp add water wait a few
days for the mycelium to grow throughout
remove the mold and you're left with a
grown 3d form incredibly we can grow all
kinds of structures using living
organisms from phones that can replace
plastics in Footwear to leather like
materials without animals furniture
flooring all are currently being
prototyped fungi are able to grow
materials that are naturally
fire-retardant without any chemicals
they're naturally hydrophobic meaning
they won't absorb water they have higher
melt temperatures than plastics
polystyrene can take thousands of years
to degrade mushroom packaging materials
can be naturally composted in your back
garden in as little as 30 days living
organisms are transforming waste into
cost competitive performance matching
materials that can start to replace
plastics and other co2 emitting
materials and once we start growing
materials with living organisms it
starts to make previous methods of
manufacture seem illogical take the
humble house brick the cement industry
generates around 8% of global co2
emissions that's more than all the
planes and ships each year the cement
process requires materials to be fired
in a kiln at over 2,000 degrees
Fahrenheit
compare this to bio Mason they use a
soil microbe to transform loose
aggregates like sand or crushed stone
into a bio fabricated or bio cement
brick their process happen
at room temperature in just a couple of
days think hydroponics for bricks an
irrigation system feeds nutrient-rich
water to trays of bricks that have been
inoculated with bacteria the bacteria
produced crystals that form around each
grain of sand locking together all the
loose particles to form a solid brick we
can now grow construction materials in
the elegant way nature does just like a
coral reef and these bio fabricated
bricks are nearly three times stronger
than a concrete block and in stark
contrast to traditional cement
production they store more carbon than
they make so if we could replace the 1.2
trillion fired bricks that are made each
year with bio fabricated bricks we could
reduce co2 emissions by 800 million tons
every year
beyond growing materials with living
organisms we're even starting to design
products that encourage their growth and
this comes from the realization that the
very thing we've been trying to
marginalize life might actually be our
greatest collaborator to that end we've
been exploring all the ways that we can
grow healthy microbes in our own
ecosystems a great example of this is
architects who are imagining the skin of
a building to function like the bark of
a tree but not as a cosmetic green layer
they're designing architectural box as
hosts for evolving ecologies these
surface structures are designed to
invite life in and if we applied the
same energy we currently do suppressing
forms of life towards cultivating life
we turn the negative image of the urban
jungle into one that literally embodies
a thriving living ecosystem by actively
encouraging surface interactions with
healthy microbes we could improve
passive climate control stormwater
management and even reduce co2 emissions
by lowering the energy used to heat or
cool our buildings we're just beginning
to realize the potential of nature based
technologies I'm excited that we're
starting to design and buy or fabricate
a new material world it's one that moves
away from the exploitation of
non-renewable resources to working with
the original renewable life instead of
designing out life we're designing with
it and for it
packaging fashion Footwear furniture
construction bio fabricated products can
be grown close to senses of demand with
local resources less land energy and
even harnessing industrial waste streams
it used to be that the tools of
biotechnology with a preserve of
powerful multinational chemical and
biotech companies in the last century we
expected material innovation to come
from the likes of DuPont Dow BASF but
this 21st century material revolution is
being led by startups with small teams
and limited capital and by the way not
all their founders have science degrees
they include artists architects and
designers over a billion dollars has
already been invested in startups by
fabricating consumer products I don't
think we have a choice but to buy or
fabricate our future from the jacket
you're wearing to the chair you're
sitting in to the home you live in
you're designed material world shouldn't
compromise your health or that of our
planet
if materials can't be recycled or
naturally composted at home we should
protect them I'm committed to making
this future a reality by shining a light
on all the amazing work being done today
and by facilitating more interactions
between designers scientists investors
and brands because we need a material
revolution and we need it now thank you
you